hello and thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's presenter dr kirk
mcmanus an associate professor in the
department of biochemistry
and medical genetics at the university
of manitoba
and senior scientist at the research
institute in oncology
and hematology at the cancer care
manitoba
canada for complete biography of dr
mcmanus please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr mcmanus
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
so my research team is interested in
identifying
the molecular origins of cancer the
second interest that we have is
exploiting that information to develop
novel therapeutic targets that
selectively exploit those defects
now to enable this research we've had to
develop and utilize
a myriad of different types of
quantitative imaging microscopy
approaches
so really today what i'm hoping to do is
present some of our findings but of
course
some of those specific approaches
we are very much interested in genome
instability and its relationship with
cancer
in fact many of you will know that up to
95
of all cancers exhibit some form of
genome instability
and there are many different forms
there's three that are listed here
microsatellite instability
cpg island methylated phenotype and what
we are interested in
chromosome instability chromosome
instability is defined as an increase in
the rate at which whole chromosomes or
large chromosomal fragments
are gained or lost and in the context of
a population of cells
this is very much a driver of cell to
cell heterogeneity
and it's often that heterogeneity that
we are assessing within those
quantitative imaging microscopy
approaches
sin is arguably best understood in
colorectal cancer context where up to 85
percent of all colorectal cancers
exhibit sin sin generally comes in two
flavor formats shown on the top left is
numerical syn
where basically we can silence one of
our favorites and genes
and convert a karyotypically stable
normal diploid cell into something that
has massive increases in chromosome
numbers
the other type is structural center
s-syn and this really refers to gross
chromosomal rearrangements
so here we're using whole chromosome
paints that should paint the entirety of
these two chromosomes either red and
green respectively
but you can see some sort of
translocation event has occurred
so what you really have to think about
is the changes in
gene copy numbers and or their local
environments that are associated with
both numerical and structural sin
and how these really help cancers
develop
why do we care about sin so much well we
imagine
um sin really could be a nefarious
blackjack dealer who's not only
shuffling the genome
but bringing in and throwing out cards
that really stack the deck in favor of
cancer development
and progression sin is a very important
and believed to be an early event
in the etiology of cancer it is
certainly a driver of cellular
transformation
as i've already alluded to it's
important for tumor
evolution or intra-tumor heterogeneity
and you can also drive changes in
metastatic gene expression profiles
and is associated with the acquisition
of drug resistance
so consequently it's not really
surprising that sin is associated with
poor
patient outcomes now the current
limitations and
my research interests are sort of
presented on this slot
finn is certainly highly prevalent in
many different cancer types but the
molecular determinants i.e the aberrant
genes
proteins and cellular pathways that
drive chromosome instability remains
largely unknown
so our fundamental question that we try
to address through our research
is what are the aberrant genes and
pathway that give rise to sin and
contribute to cancer development
now some of this work has already been
studied extensively in model systems
like
budding yeast in fact a recent study
identified 700 out of the 6 000 yeast
genes that when deleted
basically induce a sin phenotype and
that's about
11 and a half percent of that genome if
those numbers hold true into the human
context we can expect there to be
approximately 2300 thin
genes embedded within the human genome
unfortunately however
fewer than 150 sin genes have actually
been identified and validated in human
context
so our goal is really to identify a
comprehensive list
of humans and genes why well simply this
will identify
the genes and pathways that are normally
required to maintain
chromosome stability under normal
conditions and secondly
it will give us insight into the
aberrant genes and pathways that really
drive
cancer pathogenesis and finally we
believe that by identifying those
molecular origins of cancer we can
develop
therapeutic approaches that exploit
those origins for precision
oncology benefit
so as i've alluded to already um
sin is very much prevalent in colorectal
cut cancer and so we often use this as
our
primary model for study just a little
bit of statistical information it is the
second leading cause of cancer-related
deaths in north america
and this table generally shows you the
annual incidence and death rates
within the united states and cancer and
you can see that collectively
there are about 175 000 new diagnoses
each year
and approximately 63 000 deaths each
year as well
now unfortunately in colorectal cancer
approximately
50 of those newly diagnosed individuals
are at advanced stages stage three or
stage
four and perhaps even more daunting is
that twenty percent of all these
diagnoses are stage four
with a very low um survival rate of
about
eight to fourteen percent so this really
highlights us and many other researchers
that we do not have a good handle on how
these cancers develop
and therefore we need better
understanding of how they develop so
that we can tailor
better therapeutic strategies to
minimize these
morbidity and mortality rates
so what i'm going to talk about over the
next um the remainder of this particular
presentation
is our interest in sin and its
relationship with cancer
there's going to be four specific
vignettes
the first vignette is going to talk
about the quantitative imaging
microscopy approaches that we
developed to be able to look at sin in a
variety of cellular contexts including
cell lines
primary patient samples as well as
tissue microarrays
and so really we're going to show how
those assays can be applied to identify
the prevalence of
chromosome instability or skin within
cancer we've done this with colorectal
cancer but i'm going to show you
application to ovarian cancer
the third vignette is really going to
talk about the pathogenic origins if we
can
prove that sin is associated with these
cancers what are the aberrant genes that
are actually driving that skin
phenotype and the fourth one that i'll
go into are the therapeutic strategies
that are
designed to specifically exploit defects
in those fin genes through synthetic
lethal paradigms
some of our work as far as identifying
single targets and more recent work
where we're trying to look at
combinatorial approaches
so to begin with i'll start with the
first vignette which is really can we
develop assays to rapidly detect
sin and this is work that was done by a
very talented phd student we're at
thompson with assistance from a summer
student
and the first assays that we developed
are nuclear area analysis
and very simply put you can imagine that
the nucleus
is essentially the bag that holds the
dna so if you stuff more dna or more
chromosomes into this bag that bag will
expand
so shown here on the left are the images
these are the control cells and what
you'll notice for the nuclei in this
field of view is that they're all very
similar in size and
shape however when we silence one of our
favorite sin genes
smc-1a you generally notice two
differences
first and foremost these seem to have a
much larger
nuclear area than those are the
corresponding controls
and secondly we're seeing a lot more
heterogeneity
so by collecting series of images from
these particular conditions
and assessing hundreds to thousands of
nuclei
we can get an appreciation for the
overall distribution of nuclear areas
relative to the various different
conditions
so each one of these dots just to
orientate you represents a single
nucleus that was analyzed within these
images
and you can generally see with that
positive control silencing of smc one
we again see an increase in the overall
range
and of course an increase in the mean
that is statistically different from
those of the untreated
or control silence condition the second
assay that we use is the micronucleus
formation assay for those of you that
are unaware this is a micronucleus here
which is really defined as an extra
nuclear body found outside that primary
nucleus
and the presence of micronuclei are very
much hallmarks of chromosome instability
so similar experimental set up to that
on the left when we silence their
favorites in gene smc 1a
we certainly see an increase about a six
to seven fold increase relative to those
control
and that of course is statistically
significant
the final assay that we've really
developed and i'm going to discuss today
is chromosome enumeration probes
these are fish-based probes that
differentially label
the pericentric regions of chromosomes 8
11 and 17.
this karyogram simply verifies that
within mitotic
spreads we can see that chromosomes
correctly localize to the right
chromosomes as well as those pericentric
regions
now those step probes are applied to
really assess
interphase cells and so the top image
here
is really three interphase nuclei that
are diploid
at least for these three chromosomes so
they harbor the expected number of
two foci for each of those specific
chromosomes that's interrogated
contrasting on the bottom here what you
see is a larger nucleus which would
suggest there may be
increases in chromosome numbers and
indeed when we go and count the number
of
foci within this interphase nucleus we
see four copies of chromosome 8
3 of 11 and 3 of 17 which is obviously
in excess of the typical diploid state
so what we went on to do then was to
develop a metric referred to as
a syn score which really describes
deviations from that diploid state
so all three of these nuclei have a syn
score of zero simply because they have
the expected number of two copies of
each of those chromosomes
however this bottom nucleus has extra
copies of chromosomes
in essence two extra properties of
chromosome eight
an extra copy of chromosome 11 and an
extra
copy of chromosome 17 for a total syn
score in this case of four now by
imaging
uh by analyzing a series of
images and upwards of hundreds of nuclei
from a given condition
we can really get an approved
appreciation for the deviation that is
observed
in these various different conditions
so having developed these particular
assays we then want to apply them and
have applied them in a variety of
different cellular contexts
and what i'm going to present to you in
the second vignette is really our
efforts to discern whether or not sin is
associated
in dynamic and epithelial ovarian cancer
now ovarian cancer is very much known to
have genome instability but chromosome
instability really had not been assessed
and this collaborative work done in
collaboration with dr zalon altman and
mark machulo from the university of
manitoba
was driven primarily by sidney and is
being extended by claire and
molly farrell
so the three fundamental research
questions we had
were can we assist in eoc
i.e in those patient samples obviously
you can
because i wouldn't be here otherwise is
sin associated with
eoc samples and is it dynamic with
disease progression
and or treatment response so how did we
assess sin in these eoc samples
well we used that nuclear area analysis
that i just showed you earlier on
as well as the step analysis that i
showed you earlier on as well
and just to remind you we're collecting
series of images
in which we can do that analysis now one
of the unique things
of this particular study is the
accessibility of ascites fluid
and tumors that have been isolated from
those societies from some women with
hybrid serous ovarian cancers
that allows us unique temporal insight
into disease progression
and treatment response so here what
happens is the gynecological oncology
faculty and residents collect that
ascites through parasympasis
we are able to isolate the tumor cells
to basically 100
purity they're put on microscope slides
the fish-based approach is employed
and then we do the quantitative image
analysis for nuclear areas and those syn
scores and what i'm going to do over the
next three slides is really just throw
you
show you three specific patients that
really provide some fundamental insight
into the temporal
progression the first question that we
were trying to address is whether or not
sin is associated with epithelial
ovarian cancer
here is a patient who refused any sort
of treatment eoc
so we're really gaining insight into the
normal biology of disease progression
in this case we were fortunate enough to
obtain six samples that were able to
grow
and those are indicated here on this
specific timeline
now what i'm going to show you first are
nuclear areas so that y-axis is a change
in nuclear area
the x-axis are the different uh samples
in chronological order
and what i first want you to note is
that there's a fair amount of
heterogeneity in each of these
particular samples that heterogeneity or
cell
cell heterogeneity is really an
indicator of chromosomal instability
and in fact what this might suggest is
as this disease is progressing
the amount of aneuploidy or the level of
sin might
be increased similarly when we look
at those syn scores again i remind you
that diploid state is set at zero so
anything above that diploid state is
showing gains or losses in chromosome
numbers
and similar to what you see with the
nuclear areas you can certainly see a
fair amount of heterogeneity in each of
these samples that's indicative of sin
and perhaps within that last sample an
indication that perhaps we're seeing it
be dynamic and increasing
with disease progression now for
orientation purposes i've put a blue
dashed line
here at a cs score of eight that
indicates that any given sample below
that has lost no
loss or gain no more than eight total
chromosomes of the three
that are being assessed okay so the next
question is whether or not sin is
dynamic
in these particular patients here's a
different patient eoc13
who has recurrent disease we were able
to isolate
four samples one immediately prior to
any treatment of surgery
and then three in rapid succession after
the disease recurred
including sample f which is
corresponding to
a second line treatment with
genocitabine
when we look at the nuclear areas we see
again
starting with heterogeneity in sample a
that heterogeneity appears to
increase a to c to d and it's perhaps
chopped back a little bit
as shown by the interquartile ranges
shown in red which happens to be the
same sample that coincides with that
secondary treatment so this may suggest
that this individual's disease is
responsive to that particular treatment
similarly when we look at syn scores we
again see that heterogeneity we perhaps
see that increase
through samples a through d and it might
decrease a little bit in sample f
so it certainly appears to be dynamic
and potentially responsive to treatments
in this case
the final case that i'm going to show
you is really designed to address the
question
is sin dynamic in resistance disease
so this is someone with resistant
disease resistant disease being
clinically defined as
disease recurrence within six months of
the final treatment
we obtained four samples from this
individual one immediately prior to any
treatments
one after she was being platinum
resistant we had a third sample
and then a fourth sample that was
collected while she was undergoing
treatment with calyx which is liposomal
doxorubicin similar to what i showed you
in the previous one we see that
increasing amount of heterogeneity from
b
through g that's chopped back a little
bit h
and we see the same sort of thing with
those syn scores as well
but what i want to draw your attention
to here is that same blue line
with a syn score of eight and what
you'll notice in these last few samples
is that she has a large number of nuclei
with tremendous amount of aneuploidy or
stimulating them
so that extensive amount of aneuploidy
or high levels of sin
occurred shortly before she ultimately
succumbed to the disease
so we think it may be a biomarker
indicating
a worse patient outcome so what did that
extensive sin
actually look like so this is that same
patient you can see sample b
as shown here the nuclei there are there
is a little bit of heterogeneity
but not a lot contrast that with sample
g which is
immediately post being deemed platinum
resistant
and you see very dramatic differences
first and foremost you see a lot more
heterogeneity you see
increases in nuclear shapes and sizes
and you see a lot more of those foci
within each of those nuclei
all three of these images are actually
taken to scale and this is actually a
giant
nucleus found within the sample and when
we did the counts of those three
specific sets
we noted that there could be upwards of
43 copies of chromosome 8
up to 33 copies of chromosome 11 and
up to 22 copies of chromosome 17 so well
in excess
of the normal two that we should uh
normally find
so as far as a summary conclusion for
this vignette are concerned we certainly
can detect
and assess sin that it's prevalent and
dynamic in eoc and that it changes with
time
treatments and drug resistance the data
also suggests that sin may be a novel
disease biomarker
that may have clinical relevance for
progression
and or treatment response however we do
recognize that we need larger patient
cohorts
to really flesh that information out and
so we're obviously expanding
into additional samples with a
particular focus on hybrid serous
ovarian cancer
because the majority of these women
ultimately could succumb
to drug resistant disease ideally we
want to expand
circulating tumor cells why simply put
only about 30 percent of women present
with the society so we think this is a
great way
to expand our analysis to all of those
women potentially in other cancer types
as well
so having really demonstrated and shown
that sin is prevalent
here in ovarian cancer we then wanted to
go on and discern whether or not we
could identify
and characterize the sin genes that are
causing that chromosome instability
in those various different cancer types
again this is work done by laura
thompson
so here laura used a multiplexed
approach
for high content imaging where she was
assessing both the nuclear areas and the
micronucleus formation that i showed you
earlier on
and the fundamental question here is can
i identify
candidates in genes that are capable of
converting a karyotypically stable cell
line
into a curiosity unstable cell line
simply by decreasing their protein
expression
so what she does here is take those
karyotypically stable cells we use two
different cell lines for this screen
she sees it into a library an sio and a
based library
that has a variety of different elements
to it it has controls both negative and
transfection controls as well as
positive control such as smc 1a that i
showed you earlier on
and in this case it has 164 candidates
and genes that were identified through
cross-species canada gene approaches
so these 164 genes are the human
orthologs of
subset of the sin genes that have been
identified and yeast
so those genes are silenced within those
stereotypically stable
cells for about four days upon which
they're fixed
their counterstand subjected to the high
content imaging where we do the same
phenotype and do the quantitative
analysis for the nucleus and
micronucleus formation
that allows us to prioritize those
particular genes and do subsequent
time-consuming cytogenetic analysis to
really validate those
cn genes so what i'm going to show you
now are only the results from one of
those
screens for the nuclear is in one of the
cell lines in this case it's h-tert
which is a karyotypically stable
immortalized fibroblast
the negative control is shown down here
in red
and what you'll notice is we identified
112
putative syn genes that induce
statistically significant differences in
the overall distributions relative to
fat control
those on in blue basically are
statistically significant
decreases in nuclear areas whereas those
in green are statistically significant
increases and what i want to draw your
attention to is this yellow one
here which is skip one because i'm going
to go into greater detail in subsequent
slides
we also did this for ht1080 cells shown
here
are the micronuclei data from the screen
in those hd 1080 cells these are
arteriotypically
stable fibroceromonal cell line sass is
a little bit different we're looking for
the appearance of these micronuclei and
the frequency in them
and so what we can see here in red is
the negative control
and anything in green on the right
basically exhibits or exceeds the
minimum threshold required to be
identified as significant and worth
pursuing
and that level of significance is two
times the standard deviation of that
negative control
again i highlight this yellow one which
is silencing of skip one which certainly
also induces increase in micronucleus
formation
so collectively these two assays and
those two different cell lines give us
this venn diagram
on the left you can see the two cell
lines for nuclear areas on the right you
can see those same two cell lines for
micronucleus formation
the surprising thing perhaps is that 148
out of 164 of those genes that were
screened
gave a positive result in at least one
of these assays
um but laura really wanted to go on and
to validate a subset of these and
obviously she wanted to go after the
best ones
so those are the ones that were actually
identified
as punitive candidates from at least
three out of those four conditions and
the ten genes that she went on to
validate are shown here she went on to
do a lot more drill down biology in
terms yes they do induce changes in
chromosome numbers
but what i'm going to focus on for the
remaining part of this vignette
is skip one skip one is the
s phase kinase associated protein one it
is part of the scf complex which is an
e3 ubiquitin ligase complex that
regulates the expression of hundreds of
proteins
and in particular it's very well known
to regulate cell cycle regulated
proteins
such as cyclin 1. and this schematic
really shows how that generally
functions
you can see the scf complex here you can
see where skip 1 is
that normally attracts a particular
substrate it becomes polyubiquitoulated
which targets it for proteolytic
degradation by the fat 26s
proteasome however what we think is
happening when we silence skip one
is we lose skip one expression we no
longer have a functional
scf complex those substrates are no
longer polyubiquity or degraded
and as a result those substrates
accumulate
and we think that substrate accumulation
induces sin
and or cellular transformation
so if that was true what you'd expect is
to see that skip one is altered in a
myriad of different
cancer types and indeed we went into the
cancer genome atlas to look up some of
this information you can see these are
the prevalence
and frequency of mutations deletions and
other alterations within a variety of
different cancer types
and i'm going to be the first to admit
the alteration frequencies are not great
in any of these cases
however when we look at shallow
deletions or heterozygous loss
i.e loss of one functional allele
those frequencies are much greater in
fact if we look at some of the cancer
types that i was just talking about
ovarian cancer for example approximately
45
of all ovarian cancers are expected to
have the loss of one skip one
wheel and annually in the united states
in canada
that would equate out to about ten and a
half thousand people similarly
colorectal cancer found in a lower
frequency only about 14
but that equates to about 24 000
individuals in the united states and
canada
annually and when we go on to look at
the expression analysis
and impact on case patient outcomes
we can see that individuals with
colorectal cancer that have
low skip one mrna expression fare worse
than those with high
levels of expression so collectively
these clinical data shown here in
combination with the initial screen
results
certainly support the possibility that
diminished skip one expression
may be a pathogenic event in the
development of a myriad of different
cancers and in particular colorectal
cancer
so laura went on to do a lot of
validation she went on to
demonstrate that she could use
individual s i rnas in order by dash 1
or dash 2 or a pooled sir
a-based approach which is comprised of
four independent
sir a's she could very much silence skip
one in
these h-hurt cells and that that
silencing corresponds with statistical
increases in nuclear areas
as well as micronucleus formation so
certainly supportive of the initial
screen
event and of course she extended this to
a myriad of other
cancer cell lines as well and saw very
similar
findings she then went on to actually
look at the chromosomes and look at
numerical sin so here's the control
where we can see 46 chromosomes
when she silences skip one she certainly
sees differences that can certainly
occur
in this case we counted only 45
chromosomes which obviously is a loss of
one so it's small scale loss
in this specific example she sees
basically a doubling of the genome to 92
chromosomes which is obviously a large
scale gain and in fact through further
scrutiny of this particular image you
can actually see that
uh chromosomes appear to have been
doubled so they're paired up
in each of these particular cases and
that's suggestive of endo reduplication
which is a subsequent round of
s phase independent of any sort of
cytokinetic event
she also went on to look at structural
sin or evidence of structural sin
and shown here in this spread you can
see evidence from those arrowheads
of dna double strand breaks within each
of those sister chromatids
she also saw evidence for chromosomal
shattering which is believed to be a
mechanism
giving rise to chromotrips and of course
she can quantify all of those data and
in those silence
conditions relative control she's always
seeing statistically significant
increases now based on this information
and further scrutiny of
some of these particular images you
could begin to gain insight into some of
the aberrant
pathways that may be contributing to sin
and these phenotypes
and those phenotypes include replication
stress and dna damage
so laura went on to do a quantitative
imaging microscopy approach where she
immunofluorescently labeled cells for
rpa which is a single strand
binding protein and really an indicator
of replication stress
and you can see in the control condition
we see very low levels of rpa which is
expected
however in that positive control cells
treated with hydroxyurea we see a
dramatic
increase in the abundance of rpa
labeling
that is very similar in the skip one
silence condition
and indeed you can also see the
increased sizes of those nuclei relative
to the control
and of course laura went on to quantify
that and those increases in rpa labeling
are certainly statistically significant
moving forward she also did a very
similar approach
for dna double strand breaks she used
gamma h2ax which is a surrogate
indicator of dna double strand breaks
and rather than just doing total signal
intensities she looked at the number of
foci within these particular
cells and classified those either below
five or above five and that's indicated
in black
so what you can see in the positive
control in the skip one silence
condition
is an increase in the number of cells
that harbor more than
five gamma h2ax foci basically a four to
five fold increase relative to those
controls
so these observations really allowed
lord to conclude that skip one silencing
increases replication stress and dna
damage
so she really wanted to know well what
could be the mechanism that connects
skip one silencing with all of these
particular defects
and so through literature searches she
came up with cyclin
e1 cyclin e1 is very interesting for a
variety of reasons
first and foremost it is an established
oncogene
secondly the cyclin e1 gene
is genomically amplified and contributes
to the development of 20
of all high-grade serous ovarian cancers
and that over-expression either in
individuals or alternative
to animal modeling is associated with
increases in replication stress dna
double strand breaks in sin
and certainly drives cellular
transformation
many of those phenotypes that i just
showed you and surprisingly
increases in cyclin e1 expression
correspond with worst patient outcome
and that's shown here for hydrate serous
ovarian cancers
where high levels of cycling expression
because it's an oncogene
correspond with worse overall survival
so i already alluded to it earlier on uh
cycling e1 is indeed targeted by the scf
complex at least within the literature
so what we think is going on
is this scf complex is no longer
functional due to the loss of skip one
expression
as a result cycling e1 does not
turn over and it accumulates and it will
have implications for
g1 s phase transition or replication
as well as centrosome biology so
laura really set out to really
demonstrate some of those particular
issues
but first she wanted to establish the
relationship between diminished skip one
expression
and the expected increase in cyclin e1
levels
so again she did her indirect
immunofluorescent quantitative imaging
microscopy approach where she labeled
cells with antibodies targeting
cyclin e1 and in the control you can see
a little bit of labeling that's there
generally it's cell cycle regulated so
it's only expected to be in a subset of
cells
when she silences cyclin e1 it all but
disappears
and when she silences skip one it is
dramatically increased and virtually all
nuclei and again those nuclei
are large she certainly can quantify
that at the single cell level
so we see large-scale increases that are
statistically significant
relative to the control and if that
wasn't convincing enough she of course
went on to do a western blot
where she could effectively silence skip
one and that silence and corresponded
with an
increase in abundance of cycling e1
so if the assumption is reduced skip one
expression
induces increase in cyclin one that
caused those two genotypes
if we co-silence skip one with cyclin e1
we would expect to minimize or
phenotypically rescue those aberrant
phenotypes
and that's shown here in this actual
image where we have a skip one silence
condition and we have relatively large
nuclei
when we cosine skip one with cyclin e1
we begin to see
smaller nuclei so a rescue of that
phenotype
and so she went on to quantify this in
the various different conditions that
are shown here
i'm really only going to draw your
attention to the skip one silence
conditions
that when she then goes on and does the
dual silencing
she sees a statistically significant
decrease in the overall
ranges or interquartile ranges as well
as the mean values
now those data presented a slightly
different way are shown here we're
looking at the cumulative distribution
frequencies of those nuclear areas
so shown in gray and black are the s-i
control
and skip um sorry cycling one silenced
conditions
shown in red are the skip one silence
condition
and shown in blue is the dual skip one
cycling
one silencing condition and what i want
to draw your attention to
is that this blue line is moving away
from those reds
back towards those negative controls
although not all the way
so this certainly identifies that a part
of this mechanism
involves the accumulation of cyclone e1
and of course she went on to look at
micronucleus formation and aberrant
chromosome numbers and each of these
relative to those
skip one silence conditions are
basically decreasing these aberrant
phenotypes by about 50
so this really shows that at least a
part of this mechanism
is going through aberrant cyclin e1
expression
so as far as the summary and conclusion
or concern for this vignette there
certainly is a high degree of
evolutionary conservation of sin genes
about 90
between yeast and humans that skip one
is certainly
a novel sin gene silencing is associated
with increases in nuclear areas micro
nucleus formation
and increases in chromosome numbers it's
also associated with increases in
replication stress and dna damage
and increases in cyclin e1 abundance
however we do believe there are likely
to be additional proteins involved
in the development of some of those
aberrant phenotypes
in addition this certainly shows that
aberrant cyclin e1 turnover induces sin
and suggests it may contribute to
oncogenesis in a similar manner
to the genomic amplification of the
cyclin e1 gene
that occurs in high grade zeros ovarian
cancer
so this is really exciting because it
shows that these aren't changes that are
occurring at the genome level but rather
are changes that are occurring at the
protein level
so we believe vibrantly high levels of
cyclin e1
may be a major contributor to the
development and progression of
hydrate serious ovarian cancers or
perhaps other cancer types as well
in addition these findings certainly
suggest that additional scf complex
members may
also be fingers and in fact members of
the lab have looked at rbx 1
call 1 and some of the f box proteins
and show that they
are sin genes and that some of the
mechanisms are certainly complementary
but also distinct as well
and that is ongoing research so
having identified those same genes the
next
final vignette is really broken into two
and the first part
is can we exploit defects in those thin
genes to develop precision medicine
therapies
and so this really begs the question
well how exactly do you exploit
genes that are missing or underexpressed
and this is done through a concept
that's well
understood in cancer now that certainly
was born out of
model organisms like yeast and it's
referred to as synthetic lethality
now synthetic lethality is defined as
the lethal combination
of two independently viable mutations
now to put that in simpler sort of
context or analogy i have the following
schematic
what you can imagine is that we're
trying to exploit a cancer-causing
mutation perhaps one of those thin genes
like skip one i just spoke about
and we're trying to identify a rare
interaction
that will exploit the defect found in
that thin gene
i think many of you are familiar with
mentos and then if you drop mentos into
diet coke you have a nice explosion
and that's a very rare event you can't
take other candies or chocolates or
other things and drop them into diet
coke and have that
effect so what essentially we're trying
to do is identify those drug
targets or those mentos that will be
able to exploit those same genes
and if we can do that at the level of a
tumor hopefully we would have a nice
explosion as we
sort of demonstrated here so we're going
to shift gears and we're now going to
talk a little bit about rad 54b
we've been looking at this gene for over
a decade now
it is an evolutionarily conserved gene
from yeast all the way up into humans
both the yeast and the human
forms encode functions within the dna
double strand break repair pathway
and more specifically within homologous
recombination repair which i remind you
is that error-free
repair pathway rad54b is mutated in a
variety of different cancer types such
as those that are shown here
and what we showed uh over a decade ago
is that sirna-based silencing or genetic
manipulation of rad54b
corresponds with increases in dna
content
that also correspond with changes in
chromosome numbers
so rad 54b is certainly a chromosome
instability gene that we hope to exploit
through synthetic lethal approaches so
one of the nice things about rad54b
is it has a yeast ortholog that has been
studied for synthetic lethality
for a long time and there's a lot of
synthetically for interactors that have
been identified
so what we wanted to do is query the
human orthologs
of those synthetic lethal interactions
to see if we could identify some of
those synthetic lethal interactions
whether or not they're conserved in the
human context
so basically we take cells these are
isogenic cells
one is control so it's rad 54 be
proficient and the other one is rad 54b
deficient we transfect the cells with
those candidate
targets or those candidate drug targets
we allow them to grow for about four and
a half days at which point they're fixed
in an image and then we can do our
analysis
to see how many cells remain within each
of those wells
so the genes that were screened there's
about 80 of them that are shown here
these were identified again through
those cross-species candidate gene
approaches
and how this generally works is we take
the proficient control cells
or the deficient experimental cells see
them independently
into two identical libraries allow them
to grow
and then on a well by well basis
generate a
synthetic leaf a ratio
which would really identify those
instances where there's a dramatic
decrease in cellularity within this
condition
relative to this condition so here's
what a synthetic
lethal interaction would look like just
to orientate yourself the proficient
control cells are on the left the
deficient
and rock out cells are shown on the
right these are both silenced with the
same si rna
and at the end point of the experiment
you can certainly notice
a dramatic decrease in the number of
nuclei of cells that are remaining
within the deficient cells
in addition the arrowheads are
highlighting cells that are exhibiting
hallmarks associated with cellular set
of toxicity
and actually if you really scrutinize
those images they are exhibiting
hallmarks associated with apoptosis
so this initial screen out of the 80
genes that were
screened 32 of them gave a putative
hit as far as this type of relationship
and suggest elected to pursue sod 1 or
superoxide disney phase one
as one of those candidate new drug
targets well why did he choose
superoxide dismutase one
this is it here basically what sod one
does
is it dismutates superoxide radicals
down into oxygen and hydrogen peroxide
which is further reduced into
oxygen and water now hydrogen peroxide
and superoxide radicals are reactive
oxygen species
and those reactive oxygen species have
essential signaling
roles within the cell but what we reason
is
if we prevented this from happening we
have an increase in reactive oxygen
species
which certainly causes a variety of
different types of cellular damage and
most importantly for us
is an increase in dna double strand
breaks those double strand breaks can
only be repaired through two pathways
non-homologous end joining or homologous
recombination repair but i remind you
that these are rad 54b deficient cells
so this pathway really is non-functional
so it forces these cells to repair
through an error-prone pathway
that we think will overload the system
and ultimately lead to apoptosis
now i want to draw your attention here
that sod one's dismutation
activity really requires copper as an
essential cofactor
and that'll be become important in a
couple of slides
so suggest set out to prove this
particular pathway or this working model
whether or not it's true so first and
foremost he
repeated the experiments with both
individual frnas as well as a pooled
approach
this is again a similar image the
control cells on the top the deficient
cells on the bottom
silence with the same srna a dramatic
decrease in the number of cells
remaining and again
showing hallmarks associated with
cytotoxis
that's quantified here where we can
actually
look at the number of cells remaining
and the control cells are all shown in
white
the black cells are the rad 54b
deficient cells and you can see a
dramatic decrease in the number of cells
so these data really confirm that rad
54b and sod one are synthetic
lethal and further identify sawed one as
a novel drug
target worthy of further study and so
part of the reason that sod 1 was also
selected was the availability of
inhibitors
and inhibitors of forces in air quotes
and you'll see why in a moment
we use ammonium tetrathiomolipdate
which isn't necessarily a sod one
inhibitor per se but is actually a
copper chelator
and if you recall earlier on copper is
that essential cofactor for
um sod one activity qma2 is not
a sod one inhibitor but rather a general
inducer of
ross so we reason that these two
compounds would penal copy the
uh sir and a base silencing result
and be more effective within the rad54b
deficient cells relative to the control
and that indeed is the case you can see
that the red lines the deficient cells
are hypersensitive relative to the rad
54b proficient cells
and that a therapeutic window does
indeed open
up so that really allowed suggest to go
on and really characterize that initial
working model
so the first thing we wanted to prove is
that treatment with aggm or tumi2
would induce ross on the left is the
proficient control cells and the right
are the deficient experimental cells
really drawing your attention to the
middle column in each of these
particular panels
you can see that treatment with atpm and
2 as expected
induces loss within each of these
different isogenic
cell lines and of course that can be
quantified as well
the assumption is we had an increase in
loss and that would lead to an
increase in dna double strand breaks so
again
suggest went on to test that with two
antibodies
that really are surrogate indicators of
dna double strand breaks
53bp1 and gamma h2ax
again this is a slightly different
experiment where
those drugs are pulsed initially into
these
cells and then they're washed out and
those cells are allowed to recuperate
for 36 hours so as expected in both of
these cell lines we see an increase
in labeling for those particular
antibodies indicating an
increase in dna double strand breaks
upon washout we notice at the bottom
here
that there is a dramatic decrease in
those particular levels within the
control cells but that those levels
persist or remain within the rad 54b
deficient cells
certainly showing that those dna double
strand breaks are not being adequately
or properly repaired
in the rad 54v deficient cells and of
course we can quantify that and those
differences
are statistically significant relative
to the corresponding
control cells so with that
we certainly are seeing increases in dna
double strand breaks the evidence
earlier on
suggested that it perhaps was through an
apoptotic mechanism
so we went on to again do quantitative
imaging microscopy
this time looking at cleaved caspase-3
which is basically the point at which
the intrinsic and extrinsic pathways
converge so with respect to cleave
caspase-3 we use the positive control
stores foreign which certainly
increases um cleave cast phase 3 in both
of those cell lines
but really the increases in cleave
caspase-3 were restricted to
those rad 54b deficient cells and were
not really evident within those rad 54b
proficient cells and again we can
quantify that information here
so that really led to the current
working model where we can use sirna
based
silencing or alternatively atgm or 2ma2
which all induce increases in loss
subsequently we also identified lcs1
which is a bonafide sod one inhibitor
identified by hero's pharmacist group
all of these induce increases in ross
that correspond with increases in
persistence of dna double strand breaks
um and ultimately
cause death through an apoptotic
mechanism
now these findings for rad 54b certainly
are suggestive that other members
of a homologous recombination repair
pathway may
also be sensitive synthetically for
targeting of software
so we've certainly begun to investigate
other genes that encode
functions within that pathway and have
shown that sod 1
does indeed have broad spectrum
applicability
so for us that's very exciting and we're
going to continue this work
in sort of the combinatorial approaches
that i'll now show you
so this really leads to the end of this
particular vignette can we enhance the
therapeutic killing that we saw
the use of combinatorial approaches and
this is work done by aaron
and chloe a couple of years ago
so here we're trying to identify
synergistic combinations of drugs
so i didn't show you the data you're
going to have to trust me that rad 54b
is synthetic lethal with bmm673 which is
a part
inhibitor so we're looking at everything
in the context of bmn 673 and changing
those concentrations and the different
drugs for trust too
so just to draw your attention and make
sure you understand the concept drug one
by itself has a particular effect
perhaps certain amount of killing drug
two in this case has an equal amount of
killing such that when you add the two
of them together if it's additive it's
simply
the product uh sorry the the result of
these two
added together if it's antagonistic it's
below that additive effect and if it's
synergistic which from a clinical
perspective is what we really want then
it
has if you will super killing in this
particular case
so shown here are just one example of
each of those three categories
we have bmn 673 with 5fu or
5-fluorouridine which is usually part of
a chemotherapeutic regiment for
colorectal calcium you can see the two
different drug concentrations shown
there
and this axis is basically the
percentage of cells
remaining this is an additive result you
can see bmn 673 with two methoxy ester
dial
has an antagonistic effect so it's not a
combination we would want to pursue
and dmn673 in the context of lcs one
certainly has that synergistic impact or
that sweet spot that we would want to
use
forward now from a clinical perspective
obviously these are the ones that we
want to identify and move forward
through pre-clinical tests
but these combinations are also
important because you would not want to
combine these and give them to patients
because these potentially could
increase tumor aggressiveness and or
growth
so what i'm wanting to show you on the
next couple of slides are some of the
movies that we've generated to look at
these combinatorial approaches
and we're really doing this using that
biotech system that we have which is the
biospa 8 in combination with the
citation 3.
so these experiments are performed in 96
well
round bottom plates cells are seated in
that
and what you can see here initially are
those individual cells and as this movie
plays
you'll see them coalesce together form
that tumor spheroid and begin to grow
over the time course of this imaging
which is roughly two weeks
and so what this really allows us to do
is basically try those various different
combinations to see if they
impact on cellular growth and this
particular 3d spheroid model is
obviously much more akin to what you
might see
in an individual although it's very much
smaller
and it's more representative than the
traditional 2d culture systems that
are used by many groups so this next
movie really begins
at this time point here this is where
that tumor spheroid has
formed and it's at this point where bmn
673 as well as lcs1 has been
supplemented into the media
the media is also supplemented with
propidium iodide which is the
fluorescent marker of
death and so as we watch this particular
movie what you'll see
is those cells begin to die in that
tumor spheroid
beginning from the outside and working
their way in towards the core of this
particular sphere
and of course by doing replicates and
multi wells for all of these various
conditions we can basically use that
fluorescence
indicator as a indicator of cell death
and so here we can actually quantify
that we have three different conditions
bmm-673 by itself
lcs one by itself and the two in
combination
you can see the concentration of bmn 673
that we're using really has no effect
on death in these particular tumor
spheroids very low concentration
however lcs one does appear to induce
death as a result but when we combine
those two drugs in those identical
combinations we see this purple line
which is indicative of greater levels
of killing so that synergistic effect
so for us this is very exciting work
that is leading us to additional
pre-clinical models to identify those
best combinatorial approaches to migrate
forward
so as far as an overall summary of
today's talk is concerned
you hopefully can see how we're
interested in sin and its relationship
with cancer
how we develop those quantitative
imaging microscopy approaches
and applied them to identify the
prevalence of sin in cancer to identify
those pathogenic origins or syn genes
and how we can exploit that information
to develop
therapeutic strategies that selectively
exploit cancer cell fibrin defects in
those
thin genes as both single agents as well
as through combinatorial approaches
and finally i'd like to acknowledge
those individuals and groups responsible
for this work
certainly like to highlight all past and
present lab members
as well as a lot of fruitful
collaborations in particular
like to highlight brad larson who was
instrumental in assisting us with our
micronucleus formation assays and
certainly we'll be doing a number of
presentations later today as well
i'd also like to highlight and thank
cancercure manitoba the tumor bank in
particular
and all those women who provided their
bio specimens for us
i'd also like to thank all the funding
groups that are shown along that bottom
row and finally a special thank you to
biotech
for being a wonderful partner that's not
only assisted
us to advance our research but for their
invitation to speak
to you today so with that i thank you
very much
and would be happy to answer any
questions
thank you dr mcmanus for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of
this webinar and if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now
just simply click on the ask a question
box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions
already coming in
dr mcmanus our first question is can you
describe
the micronuclei assay in more detail
how is this uh quantitative can it be
fully automated
uh so thank you for the question uh yes
i'll start with for the
the end of that question yes it can and
it is actually fully automated so
you essentially collect your images we
generally collect between
um 9 and 16 images per well in a 96 well
plate and the analysis
is basically done by hitting a button
and getting the number of micronuclei
out at the end
so just a little bit more information on
the micronucleus assay itself
how it generally is done is in an
automated fashion
it first and foremost creates a mask
around the nucleus the primary nucleus
itself
we then set a threshold for the distance
from the nucleus
which is basically used as sort of a
surrogate indicator as to the cell body
and so that's a secondary mask and then
we ask
um the program what sort of bodies or
nuclear stain bodies are found
outside the primary mass but within that
sort of cell boundary mass and it can
give us the number of micronuclei
quantify the number of nuclei so we can
create that as as sort of an overall
percentage and we can see
changes in those frequencies depending
on the various different conditions
and statistically compare those with
relevant controls
thank you so much and is it surprising
that we see
amplification of skp1
in some cancers for example ccrcc
and the stomach so
as you would have seen in in some of our
slides
we certainly were looking at skip one
and its relationship to diminished gene
expression
um and that's what we were particularly
interested in with a specific
uh focus on um single
allelic loss heterozygous loss or sort
of those shallow deletions
it's not necessarily surprising in a
variety of different cancer types that
you see a variety of different things
happen
for any given gene the question is to
discern between those driver events and
those passenger events
so as predicted if you take your
favorite gene you certainly will see
instances where it can be amplified or
instances where it can be lost
it's really important to do those
functional analysis to discern whether
or not those gains or losses are those
critical aspects
we by no means suggest that skip one
loss of skip one expression
is the only way that we could get on
some of those particular phenotypes
and in fact with some of the genes that
we're studying independent of skip one
we can show and we're aware that these
genes can be diminished in expression or
increased in expression and both
contribute to those
phenotypes and could be pathogenic
events
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
what is the role of chromosome alignment
if and if any in the pathways that
you've been describing here
so as far as chromosomal alignment i'm
assuming what you mean is actually
congressional errors to the metaphase
plate during mitosis or alternatively
um lagging chromosomes as chromosomes
segregate
so we certainly can do live cell imaging
microscopy and quantify those there's
certainly
individuals that do a lot of lineage
tracing
we don't tend to do a lot of that with
our particular genes that we're
interested in at the moment unless we
see evidence for there could be
congressional segregation errors
in those we can also capture those
events independent of live cell
imaging basically in traditional
endpoint fixed
if we survey enough cells across enough
cover slips we certainly can see
evidence
and have counted and scored
congressional errors or lagging
chromosomes as well
dr chris mcganis thank you so much for
your time today and for your important
research
i also want to thank our audience for
their questions
and for your participation join the rest
of our presentations
today at this conference thank you all
have a great day
bye-bye my pleasure and thank you very
much as well